hey this is presh tollwalker the line 2x
minus y plus 1 is equal to zero meets
the curve x squared plus three Y is
equal to 19 at the points A and B
the perpendicular bisector of the line a
B meets the x-axis at the point C
find the area of the triangle ABC
this is one of the more challenging
homework questions I've seen in a while
and I think Xavier for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
to work this question out let's sketch
the line and the Curve
so 2x minus y plus 1 is equal to 0 is a
line
let's solve for y we'll add y to both
sides of the equation to get 2x plus 1
is equal to Y this is the slope
intercept form of a line
so this line has an intercept that's
equal to 1 and a slope that's equal to
two
so we want to draw a line that has a
positive slope of 2 that goes through
the point 0 comma 1.
so it will look something like this
now we have the curve x squared plus 3y
is equal to 19.
subtract x squared from both sides of
the equation and then divide by three
Y is equal to 19 over 3 minus x squared
over three
so this type of equation you should
recognize it's the equation of a
parabola it will have a y-intercept
that's equal to 19 over 3 and since the
coefficient on x squared is negative one
over three we know this Parabola will
Point downward
so we're going to have a maximum value
at 19 over 3 and then we'll draw a
parabola that points downward in both
directions so look something like this
now the line meets the curve at two
points A and B so how do we solve for
those two points well we know the
equations of these two graphs so we'll
set them equal to each other
now we've solved for y in both cases so
we can set these equations equal to each
other 2x plus 1 is equal to 19 over 3
minus x squared over 3.
we'll multiply both sides of the
equation by 3 so we have 6X plus 3 is
equal to 19 minus x squared
then we'll bring everything over to one
side so we have x squared plus 6X minus
16 is equal to zero
so we can try to factor this equation
and we will get lucky so 16 has factors
of eight and two so that works out
perfectly to the factors of X plus eight
multiplied by x minus 2.
so that means we have two solutions here
x is equal to negative eight and X is
equal to two now we know that Y is equal
to two X plus one so we can solve for y
in each of these cases so if x is equal
to negative 8 y will be equal to
negative 15 and if x is equal to 2 Y is
equal to 5. so we have the points
negative eight comma negative fifteen
and two comma five
where do we go from here
we need the perpendicular bisector of
the line a b
so in order to get the perpendicular
bisector it will go through the midpoint
of a b
so the midpoint of a b will be the
average of the points A and B so we can
take the simple average
of the coordinates we have negative
eight plus two all over 2 for the x
coordinate and negative 15 plus 5 all
over 2 for the y coordinate this works
out to be negative 3 comma negative 5
and we will label this point as M for
the midpoint
now we need the perpendicular bisector
to go through Point M and it needs to be
perpendicular to the line a b
now we know that the line a b
has a slope that's equal to two
so that means the line that's
perpendicular to it will have a negative
reciprocal
so this slope will be negative one over
two
now we also know that we go through the
point negative three comma negative five
so we can use the point-slope formula to
get the line that goes through cm
so it'll be y minus a negative 5 is
equal
to the slope negative one-half
multiplied by x minus a negative 3. this
works out to Y plus 5 is equal to
negative one-half multiplied by the
quantity X plus three
now let's say C is the x-intercept
so at that point Y is equal to zero so
substituting Y is equal to zero we can
solve for the x coordinate so we have
zero plus five is equal to negative one
half multiplied by X plus three
we multiply both sides of the equation
by negative two
and then subtract 3 from both sides of
the equation to get X is equal to
negative 13. so the point C is that
negative 13 comma zero
Now All That Remains is to solve for the
area of the triangle ABC
so let's take a b as the base and we
know that cm is perpendicular to it so
the area of ABC will be one half of the
length of a b multiplied by the length
of cm
so we have one more step here we need to
calculate these distances a b and c m
we can use the distance formula to do
this so we'll first calculate the length
of a b it'll be the square root of the
quantity two plus eight squared plus the
quantity 5 plus 15 squared
this works out to be the square root of
500 which is equal to 10 root 5. we now
use the distance formula to figure out
the length of cm
we go through these steps and we get
that cm is equal to the square root of
125 and that is equal to 5 root 5.
so let's substitute these values in
we have 10 root 5 multiplied by 5 root 5
all over 2
the root fives will work out to be root
5 times root 5 is equal to 5. 10 times 5
is equal to 50 so we have 50 times 5 all
over 2 so that's 250 divided by 2 and
that gives us the answer of 125.
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]